JAKE ARCHIBALD: So back
in 1995, JavaScript
was created by Brendan Eich.
And he did it in 10 days, which
is pretty crazy, that it's
what most of the
web is built of now.
JavaScript is 18
years old now, so it's
legal to drink in
some countries.
It's also on Twitter,
saying that they
think they've seen JavaScript
drunk many years ago,
a lot of the time
quite like that.
But in 2010, another team set
about making a new language.
And from what we know
now of the web-- we
know how the whole web is put
together and the kind of tools
we need.
And that team is the
Dart team, and here
to talk about it--
big warm welcome
to Seth Ladd and Kasper Lund.
SETH LADD: Thanks Jake.
So we won't be
playing the Kenny G.
We don't want you
guys to fall asleep.
This is Dart for the
modern web developer.
My name is Seth Ladd.
I'm a developer advocate with
the Chrome and Dart team.
KASPER LUND: And
I'm Kasper Lund.
I'm an engineer here at Google.
I work as a tech lead
on the Dart platform.
And before I ventured
into Dart territory,
I spent a lot of
years on optimizing V8
and the optimizing
compiler in there.
SETH LADD: OK.
So many of you know
Dart as a language.
And sure it's a structured,
scalable, familiar language,
but it's also-- I like to think
of it as a batteries included
platform.
There's a great core set
of libraries-- things
like collections, things like
asynchronous programming,
futures, streams,
things like numbers,
booleans, dates, times.
We also ship a collection
of productive tools--
a Dart Editor, an analyzer to
give you warnings and errors,
a package manager we
affectionately call Pub,
because you play darts in a pub.
We also ship a virtual machine
which runs Dart code natively.
You can run that VM on a
command line or on the server,
and you can also embed
it in client browsers.
But probably most
importantly, we
ship a Compiler to JavaScript.
So the Dart code
you see here today,
and the Dart apps that
you'll be writing,
you can compile that down
to essentially ECMAScript
5, and run it across modern
browsers, desktop and laptop.
You might have heard recently,
we launched Dart 1.0.
It was a big milestone
for us, hopefully exciting
for you guys.
The big point of this, really--
[APPLAUSE]
SETH LADD: Thank you.
The journey starts
here, really, for us.
The big point here,
the big take away,
is it's now stability
you can count on.
We've been open source
since about October 2011,
and gotten tons of feedback
from internal developers,
external developers,
hackathons, code labs.
And we've collected
that all and launched
what is now a stable language,
stable core libraries for you
to build production apps on.
So now is the right
time to try it.
OK.
So when I said you
can use Dart today,
I think I actually mean you can
use Dart like in the next hour.
So we're going to do a lightning
tour of the syntax structure
and semantics to show
you how familiar and easy
it is to get started.
So Dart, by design,
is very easy to learn.
We have semi-colons.
We have curly braces.
In fact, we got a little flak
when we first launched Dart.
People were like, why don't
you make the next big Haskell?
And we're like, we want
more than five users.
And so we wanted to make sure
that you guys can totally
understand this code.
We've run hackathons
and code labs.
People get it.
So familiar, classes.
But just because it's
a familiar language
you can dive into
in about an hour,
doesn't mean we can't
take this opportunity
to introduce new features, for
instance, with constructors.
What do we always
do in constructors?
This dot x equals x.
This dot y equals y.
This is getting boring.
So Dart says, hey, if
the name of the field
is the same as the
constructor parameter, just
say, this.strength in this case.
And that will desugar to
this.strength equals strength.
Just those nice
additions that make this
feel more terse, more scripty.
Speaking of scripty, Dart
has operator overriding.
So plus, minus, et cetera,
that's in this language.
We also named
optional parameters.
Again, it's a
structure language.
It may look like the structure
language you've been using,
but it has those
features that allow
you to have a terse programming
experience that you might
be more familiar with
than scripting languages.
In fact, this case here, hands
is an optional parameter,
but also has a
default value of one.
So say more without typing more.
We also support
one-line functions.
This is critical.
There's a lot of callbacks
going on in web programming,
and a lot of times
you want to do
really small, inline
function literals.
We support that with
the fat arrow syntax.
And we also have
string interpolation,
making it very easy and quick
to create strings, just dollar
sign, variable, or expression.
And it's right there.
It's a lot easier than doing
string builders or string
concatenation.
So Dart is its own language.
It's not just the syntax
that masks another syntax.
We have our own clean semantics.
So we want to turn more of these
"wat" moments, which I'm not
even sure what's going
on here, into the totally
awesome atomic
dinosaur nuclear rocks.
We want you to have more on
the right, less on the left.
Some examples of the cleaned
up semantics that give you
a more logical programming
experience in Dart-- only true
is truthy.
There you go.
Now you know the truthy rules.
Good job.
There is no
undefined, only null.
Yes, totally, cleaned up.
No type coercion with things
like double equals and plus.
So when you try to do something
funky, we're going to tell you.
Pop quiz time.
Here's a string "hello"
we call .missing,
which obviously does
not exist on string.
What would you want to
happen at this point?
Undefined?
I don't want undefined.
I want to be told that there's
no missing method on string.
And sure enough, at runtime,
when you hit code like this,
the program tells you
with a very clean error.
So a much more logical
programming experience.
If you were to compare
'hello', which is a string,
is it greater than one?
I think this returns
false, but actually I'm
not really sure why.
So what would you
want this to happen?
You want an error.
You want to be--
hey, man, string
does not have an instance
method greater than.
You get told at runtime exactly
where the problem happened.
Much more logical
programming experience.
Variable scope.
This one's a little bit
longer, so take a look at this.
We have a main function.
if(true), there's foo,
and then print(foo),
but there's also
a top level foo.
So the question I have for
you is-- when I run this,
what will it print?
KASPER LUND: Any takers?
SETH LADD: It's 50/50 chance.
Top top-level.
Right.
This prints top-level in
Dart, no variable hoisting.
It's a totally logical
lexical scope-- lexical
analysis-- of what's going on.
If you hand most
developers this code,
they'll be able to understand
what's going on here.
Speaking of lexical
scope, even this
is lexically scoped in Dart.
This is one of the things that
totally tripped me up earlier.
Here's a class AwesomeButton.
And in its constructor you
set up a Click Handler.
And when the button is clicked,
call this.atomicDinosaurRock.
Well, what is this
at this point?
The lexically
scoped this that is
an instance of AwesomeButton.
You give most people this
code and they will tell you
what method this is calling
on, which is, I think,
a pretty big improvement.
So that's a little
bit on the semantics,
and a little bit on the syntax.
But Dart is also
designed to scale
from just a couple
lines of code.
You could certainly write
a ten line Dart script
and have it look very scripty.
But you can scale all way up
to millions of lines of code.
Now we saw functions.
We saw classes.
We have mixins.
We have interfaces.
I want to talk about libraries,
which is a nice piece
to help you
modularize your code.
Dart libraries
are very flexible.
You simply define a
file as a library.
You can import libraries
from the core SDK.
You can import libraries from
other people, or other files.
And then you can define any
number of top level constructs
in a library.
So no more one public
class per file thing,
if you come from Java.
So in this case, two classes
and even a top level function.
In Dart, you don't have to
wrap everything in a class
if you don't want to.
So nice, scalable
structure for you to grow.
Hopefully, you
guys saw that this
is a language you can
start using right away.
But of course, we use
Dart to get onto the web.
And to get on the web, you have
to compile Dart to JavaScript.
And to do that and to
show you how it works,
I'll turn it over to Kasper
to tell you all about dart2js.
KASPER LUND: Thank you Seth.
So finally, now I
can say something.
It's wonderful.
I'm going to tell you
a little bit about how
we compile to
efficient JavaScript.
And it's very, very
important to us to make sure
that Dart runs really well
on all modern browsers,
so we put a lot of
effort into that area.
Our goals are fairly simple.
We want to generate small code,
we want to generate fast code,
and we want to make
sure that we retain
the nice, clean proper Dart
semantics while doing so.
So simple goals is a
good starting point.
But to do this, and
to do it efficiently,
we need a real
optimizing compiler,
something that
doesn't just do a one
to one translation
in a simple way.
We actually need a lot of
the neat, modern compiling
techniques we've learned
to love from other more
involved projects, like V8.
So we need function inlining.
We need loop-invariant
code motion.
We need global value numbering.
We need a lot of these
things-- type propagation,
redundant lode elimination,
dead code elimination,
and much, much more.
So we need a lot of
things in this compiler.
We want to do a good job
in optimizing your code,
so you don't have
to worry about it.
So let's take a look at a
very simple Dart method, just
to give you an impression
of what we actually
translate the code to.
Here's a main method that
allocates a few points,
and then we compute the
distance between these points.
Very simple code.
Luckily, a simple
Dart method actually
compiles to relatively
simple JavaScript too.
So you will allocate
points the same way
as you would expect it to.
The only real difference
here is that when
you call the distanceTo
method, we actually
encode the arity, the
number of parameters passed,
in the method name.
Now why do we do that?
The reason why we do that is
because in JavaScript, we're
allowed to pass any
number of arguments.
Too few or too many, it
doesn't really matter.
But usually it leads to
weird and surprising behavior
at runtime if you
do that, so we want
to be a little bit
stricter there.
So to live by Dart's proper
semantics rules there,
we actually have to
check that you're
calling with the right
number of parameters.
And the fastest
way of doing that
is just encoding it
in the method name.
If you call with
too many parameters,
you'll get an error that
that method doesn't exist.
So when you have
large applications,
you need some sort
of tool to make sure
that you're not
actually shipping
too much code to your clients.
In particular, in
the set up where
you have a nice, rich
set of core libraries
and a nice set of third party
libraries you can include,
you want to make
sure that whatever
you ship to your clients
is only the needed
bits, not all the other stuff.
To do that, we have
an implementation
of an algorithm called tree
shaking in the compiler.
It works a little
something like this.
If you have an application that
has a main method, and perhaps
a few other methods
close by, foo and baz,
but it's only calling
the foo method,
and maybe the foo
method in return
calls code pulled in
from another library--
the bar method
down on the right--
the library may actually have
unused parts too like the boo
function here-- we want
the dart2js compiler
to actually take
this set of methods
like the transitive
closure of everything
that you have available to
you, and shake it really good
and get all this stuff
that you're actually
not using out of the system.
It's a process
called tree shaking.
We do that and the
result is a lot smaller.
It only contains main, foo,
and bar, the needed parts.
So to implement this
in the compiler,
we actually go
through a few steps.
First we read all
your Dart sources.
We don't actually
parse them fully.
We don't look into
all the methods.
We just look at the
structure of your code,
find all the imports,
look at the libraries
that you depend on,
and read those in too.
When we have everything
read in that way,
and we know the
structure of your code,
we can actually start doing this
first level of tree shaking.
We have two levels.
This is the first
one, and this actually
is what we call the
resolution tree shaking.
And resolution is the process
of not really compiling
code, but just trying to figure
out what you're referring to
at certain points in the code.
So it actually starts by
looking at the main function,
and look at what kind of classes
or instances of which classes
you allocate in there, and which
other methods you're calling.
All those methods need
to go into a queue
so we can process them, parse
them, get them resolved.
And you just keep doing that
until nothing new is added
to the queue, and
then you're done.
It's relatively
simple to do this,
and it gives us a
good approximation
of cutting down everything,
but only based on method names.
We can do a little bit better.
So once we're done
with that, we actually
start the process all over
again in the compilation queue.
And this is where
we actually will
start looking at what you
really put inside your methods,
and do data-flow
analysis, and we
will track how types
flow through that code.
And that gives us
more information
about what you're
actually needing to emit.
And we do the last level of
the tree shaking at that point.
The end result is that we do a
really good job of making sure
that things that you
really don't need
are not pulled into
your application.
Finally, we actually emit
the code to a single JS file.
So you can run it
in your browser.
Fairly simple stuff.
SETH LADD: I love this because
this is the tools helping me.
I don't need to be
crafting my application.
I just let the tool analyze
my program, take care of it.
KASPER LUND: That's
the way it should be.
So let's take a look at how
this actually works in practice.
Just to give you a feel for
how dart2js does its magic,
I'm going to dive into
a well-known algorithm.
It's a constraint
solving algorithm.
The reason why I'm
choosing this one
is it's a well
understood piece of code.
It's been used to benchmark
lots of different language
limitations over the years.
It's actually part of
the Octane benchmark
Linus mentioned this morning.
So it's a well-known
piece of code.
It is structured.
It has inheritance, and
classes, and everything
we need to actually do a
good job in making your code
run fast.
So let's take a look at it.
DeltaBlue is a
constraint solver.
What does that mean?
Well, basically, it's
a fairly abstract thing
that works on
constraints on variables.
Constraints can be
one way or two way.
There are binary or unary
constraints of different kinds.
And they can be used
to, for instance,
model the constraints
involving laying out something
on your screen.
I'm pretty sure that some of
the things you just heard about
from Eric actually use
this constraint to think
of that internally
when building layouts.
So doesn't lose an
implementation of such a beast.
It uses constraints and there's
a nice hierarchy of them
with unary and binary
constraints and variables.
Let me show you a piece
of code from this thing,
to make it a little
bit more concrete.
This is a function from
the DeltaBlue algorithm.
It's fairly simple.
You don't have to understand
all the details here, but just
note that the way it works here
is that you take a variable v,
and you try to figure out all
the constraints that actually
consume that
variable, and put them
in a list that is also
passed in as a parameter.
Hopefully this code is
reasonably readable to you.
It's Dart code and to me
this looks like what I--
SETH LADD: Kind of
representative of code a lot
of us would write.
KASPER LUND: Yeah.
So in Dart, we have an
optional aesthetic type system.
So you do not have to write
the types if you really
don't want to.
Sometimes it's nice to
have the document what
a parameter means, which
is why I've done it here.
But it's important to
us to make it clear
that the types that you put
in are not actually used
for up optimization purposes,
because we don't really
know if you want
to type them in.
So we don't want to force you
into typing them in the places
where you don't want to.
So I can go ahead
and remove them.
SETH LADD: And they
might also be incorrect.
KASPER LUND: They
could be incorrect.
Anyway, I've gone ahead
and removed the types.
The semantics of this
algorithm is exactly the same,
no differences at all.
It's just a little bit shorter,
and maybe a little bit harder
to understand.
But anyway, the code is
there, it's the same thing,
and this is what we're
going to try to optimize.
So first attempt at
actually compiling this code
to JavaScript is somewhat large.
So this is the
unoptimized version
of the method you just saw.
It compiled to 500 and
something characters.
It's a little bit too long.
I'm not even sure you can read
it in the back of the hall
here.
But it works.
It has the right semantics.
Everything works as specified.
And it runs reasonably well.
But it's-- I hope you agree--
it's simply not good enough.
We want to do a lot better.
So let's try to dive into
how we actually do better
than just this blob of code.
Even though the semantics
is really important to us,
we also really care
about performance.
So what makes this big?
Well, this is just
one of the examples
of why this code is little bit
bigger than what we'd like.
So as Seth mentioned,
we have strict semantics
about what you can compare
to numbers, for instance.
So we don't want to run
into issues when you end up
emitting JavaScript code that
just ends up comparing numbers
and strengths for instance,
because we don't really
want to rely on that behavior.
So in this case
we're reading-- see
if I can get this to
progress, there we
go-- so we're reading the length
of something that probably
is an array, but
we're not quite sure.
So we don't know that the
length is actually a number.
So before we continue
to actually compare
this length against
a real number,
we have to make sure that
it actually is a number.
So we insert an explicit
check in the code that
makes sure that we don't end
up relying on this somewhat
surprising behavior
of JavaScript,
where you can compare
numbers against strengths
and get some result out.
So this adds code-- more checks.
So our challenge
is fairly simple.
We want to have clean semantics,
unsurprising behavior,
but we do not really
want those extra checks
when we're compiling
to JavaScript.
So how can we go
about doing that?
The trick is right behind
me-- global optimizations.
So we really need
to do better, and we
need to do more aggressive
optimizations in the code
to make it end up being
very fast and very good.
So let's look at that.
First up-- Dart is structured.
It has classes.
It has methods.
It has a good structure.
We can actually do
whole program analysis.
So when we compile
the program, we
can look at every
single bit in it,
and we can actually
understand what's going on.
That's a huge win for us.
This allows us to actually
do code navigation
and great refactoring tools.
But maybe even more
dear to my heart
is that we can also do a global
compile-time optimizations.
So we can actually
analyze your code,
understand the dependencies
between things,
maybe, to a certain extent,
better than what you actually
care to do yourself,
as a developer.
And then we can
optimize based on that.
It's pretty powerful.
One of things that we
do, and one of the things
that really work well for
something like DeltaBlue
and for most
applications in general,
is that we infer types.
We compute what
types we actually
will see at runtime at
different points in the code.
And the way that
works is-- Here's
a simple example
of how that works.
Main function calls
foo, that calls bar,
that calls foo again, basically.
So a bunch of functions
calling each other.
So how do we infer types for
the parameters of these things?
How do we get the
compiler more information?
Well, we start by
looking at main.
So it's very simple.
And by analyzing main we
can see that foo is actually
called with an
integer parameter.
OK, so far, so good.
So we analyze foo,
under the assumption
that this called the
integer parameter.
Do we learn something from that?
Sure.
Bar is apparently also called
with an integer parameter.
So far, so good.
We can finish this
game a little bit.
So we end up in bar.
And we realize that if bar
is called with an integer
parameter, then it
ends up calling foo
with a string
interpolated version
of that parameter,
which is a string.
So foo is now
called with a string
too, so we have to
go back and iterate.
So foo is now apparently
also called with a string.
That means bar is called
with a string too.
And finally, inside
the bar method,
we realize that that means that
print is called with a string.
So far so good.
All in all, the
compiler can actually
conclude that x and y are both
either integers or strings.
This is a very,
very simple example,
but it actually works really
well in practice for large apps
too.
So let's look at
DeltaBlue and see
how that actually works there.
It's pretty simple.
So there are a
couple of things here
we want to infer types for.
For instance, the two
parameters, like v and coll.
And the infer actually
does that by looking
at all the coll sites that
call addConstraintsConsumingTo.
And we actually learned that v
is either null or a variable,
and that coll cannot be null.
It always is a JavaScript
array, containing
only subclasses of
the class constraint.
That's pretty powerful.
So that's good to know for us.
The rest of the method
here can also be analyzed,
and we can learn something about
all these constructs in there.
So we can actually get
a pretty full picture
of what the types in here are.
So I just listed them here.
You don't have to look
at all the details,
but this is very good
information for our compiler
to have.
SETH LADD: And it does this
without running a program,
just statically
looking at the program.
KASPER LUND: This is global
analysis at compile time.
So let's make this
play to our advantage.
So here's the code
again without type
inferencing-- 526 characters.
So first thing off, we know v
is either null or a variable.
So we can do a little
bit better than just
calling this getter on it.
So we can actually
see that it always
has a property determined
by, we just fetch it.
Simple stuff.
There are other
things that we can
win even more by recognizing.
For instance, v, the
variable dot constraints.
Since v is a variable,
the constraints in there
is always an array
of the constraints.
So we don't have to go through
this calling a lengths getter
and calling an index operator.
We can just do the
real JavaScript way.
Just fetch the length and
just index into the array.
Simple stuff.
Even better, we know that
v.constraints, that length
is actually an integer.
So this whole notion of checking
whether or not it's a number
goes away.
So that is a helpful thing.
It's starting to improve.
Now the condition that we have
in the loop is turning simpler.
We can change the
y-limit to a for-loop.
And at that point we're
already down to 33%
smaller than the original
code I showed you.
We have more to go, but
it's pretty simple stuff.
coll is an array.
So this calling add
on it, in a weird way,
is not really necessary.
So we can just use
the JavaScript push
method to do that for you.
Looks good.
Even further, the t1 is
initialized in a simple way,
so that can just move
into the for-loop.
And we're down to 41% smaller
than the original JS output.
We're starting to get there.
c is known to be a
subclasses constraint,
and it cannot be nulled.
We've inferred that.
So this whole notion of checking
whether or not c is nulled
before doing a comparison-- this
is necessary because of null
and undefined in
JavaScript by the way--
we don't have to worry about
that because at least c cannot
be null.
So we can simplify the code.
It's a good thing.
Finally, we know that calling is
satisfied on c, actually always
returns a boolean.
And true is the only
truthy value in Dart,
so usually we have to compare
against true before we
branch on it.
But because a boolean is
always either true or false,
it's just fine.
We can get rid of
that last thing.
And there you have it--
an optimized version
of this method that runs fast.
It's much smaller, but it still
has exactly the same semantics.
It's just we've proven we didn't
need some of these checks.
So what's that do
to performance?
Well, here's the graph
of that over time.
So the top line is
the native Dart VM
running the DeltaBlue algorithm.
So you see that that's the
best performance we have.
And it really
comes from the fact
that Dart is
designed from the get
go to be an efficient language.
So we have a very good
implementation of that.
The next two lines might be more
interesting in this context.
The yellowish line
is actually V8
running a handwritten version
of the DeltaBlue benchmark.
This is the Octane version
of the DeltaBlue benchmark
that you might have
seen in other places.
As you can see, V8 improves
on that over time, slowly,
and that's a very good
thing for the entire web.
Maybe more interesting
to me, at least,
is that the dart2js
generated code
has improved a lot
on this benchmark.
It's still the same
V8 that runs it,
it's just that the
code we generate
is actually a little bit faster
than the handwritten version.
How could that be?
Well basically,
we do optimization
that you probably don't
want to do by hand.
Because we know the entire
structure of the app,
we can do some inlining for you,
and some code motion and things
like that for your
loops that you probably
don't care to do by hand.
So it's a little bit faster.
In general, what
we see is that we
were very close to handwritten
dart2js performance
on everything.
There are cases
where we're faster.
And unfortunately,
there are cases
where we're a little bit slower.
So anyway, the performance
looks really promising
and it's nice to be able to
write in a very clean language
and get good performance.
So let's take a look
at how you actually
go about using this Dart
thing in a real setting.
SETH LADD: Yeah, thanks Kasper.
So that's dart2js.
A little bit about
the workflow--
how and when do you apply that?
Compiling JavaScript
of course is great,
but I don't want to
do that every time.
I want those quick iterations
that the web is known for.
So what does it look like?
Well, we have a
build of Chromium
with the Dart virtual
machine embedded in it
we've actually called Dartium.
And that's where you
spend most of your time.
Those are your quick
edit reload cycles.
So let's look at
what that feels like.
Here's a build of Dart Editor.
You don't have to
use Dart Editor,
but it does ship
with the project.
It's a stripped down
version of Eclipse.
In fact, I like to show this.
I showed this screen to
somebody, and they're like,
oh you have a bug?
You're missing like 78
more preferences in there?
Like, no, no actually,
we took those out.
So it's optimized for
writing Dart code.
Probably the best
way to get started
is-- let's just
create a sample app.
So luckily, Eric showed
us Polymer before.
Dart has been porting
Polymer, polymer.dart.
So we're totally in bed with
this web components things.
We think it's the bee's knees.
Here is a sample application.
You get all the
skeleton for you.
You've got the HTML.
You've got the custom
elements, the CSS.
So let's just run this
here to see what it's like.
It's very simple here, but
we're going to run in Dartium.
See, it pops right up.
No compiles time needed.
Click me, OK button.
Click counter.
OK, cool.
So it gives you just the
core to get started with.
Let's look a little bit at how
this application is written.
Hopefully you can see this.
So the polymer
element looks pretty
much like what Eric was
showing you earlier.
So the HTML aspects of building
highly declarative apps
with Dart are very similar
to the JavaScript side.
The difference though, instead
of implementing the custom
element with JavaScript, you
can implement it with Dart.
Dart has classes, so it makes a
ton of sense to be able to say,
one class for one
custom element.
So this is cool.
And I'll show you a couple
other features, because Dart
is structured, and
this editor gives you
some nice productivity benefits.
Let's say I want to add a reset
count, and then a method here.
OK.
Code completion.
Because we can statically
analyze your program,
we know what you
can call right here.
And it's real time.
So that's pretty awesome.
Now I'll also go in and infer
the local stuff as well.
OK, that's pretty cool.
Now, the other neat thing about
statically analyzable language
is it can understand
your program.
So let's look at
this field count.
Notice how it only highlights
the uses of that field.
It's not doing a string
search and replace here.
So it leaves out some
of the other accounts,
even though obviously
it's the same string.
So we can rename.
We can say my account.
And it only renames actual
usages of that field, again
the power of a statically
analyzable language.
I'm going to undo that
because I'm scared of bugs.
OK, cool.
Once you're in an
editor, and you
have an actual virtual machine,
you can set breakpoints.
So let's go back.
We set a breakpoint there.
We're going to re-run the app.
And if I click the button, and
it all works-- yes, OK, great.
So it jumps back to
the editor, and you're
in the familiar
editing environment,
with full breakpoints.
You can inspect.
This is really cool.
I can jump in here.
I want to inspect this instance.
I don't know if you guys
can see this, actually.
Trust me, that says
count and then five,
so it's a live object inspector.
So that's really cool.
Let's move on.
This app was kind of neat,
but it's also kind of boring.
So I think we can do
a little bit better.
In fact, that gray button,
I want to make fancier.
So this is where a package
management system comes in.
Our package management
system, Pub-- and let's
see if we can go here--
has over 500 packages in it
already from our open
source community, everything
from server-side stuff
to client-side stuff,
to game, crypto, you name it.
Ah, here, look at
this-- fancy button.
OK, so our Pub package
management system
also has custom elements in it.
So if you like web components,
you want to reuse them,
package management system
is a great way to do that.
So let's make our
button a little fancy.
Let's load up the
pubspec.yaml file.
This defines my application
and its dependencies.
And certainly I
depend on polymer.
Let's depend on fancy_button.
OK, great.
So now the editor
is kicking off pub.
He's going to go download
it, and install it, and make
sure it all works for my app.
I'm a little
impatient, so I'm going
to go over here and show
you what that looks like.
We're going to go
into click-counter.
And just like regular web
components and HTML imports,
you can import the
definition of fancy button.
You can say that this
button is a fancy button.
Now this is all backed by Dart.
It's a real web component,
and it came to us
from that package
management system.
Let's see if I indeed
made it a little fancier.
So run in Dartium.
And yes, awesome.
OK.
Pink, OK.
So it's a nice
demonstration of how
you can use a package management
system and reuse code.
Finally, we need to get
this out into the wild.
It's one thing to iterate
very quickly in Dartium,
but it's another thing
to be able to-- find
my original slides, boop,
OK-- do your final testing
in production browsers like
Firefox and stable Chrome.
And this is our pub
build system comes in.
So iterate very fast with
Dartium and the editor,
and then run a
nice build process.
Now more and more
web developers are
moving to a build process that
does really nice optimizations.
For one, ours runs dart2js.
You saw some of the
nice optimizations
it can actually
do with your code.
Tree shaking-- it
can minify your app.
If it totally knows
your entire application,
it can do a really smart
job at minification.
It can also do concatenation.
It can take all
your dependencies,
all your custom elements,
and jam them all in together
into one single file, making
the deployment and performance
very, very good.
In fact, in this
particular example,
you saw we had a lot of
dependencies, third party
stuff, custom libraries,
core libraries.
This app compiles
them and gzips down
to smaller than some CSS
frameworks you guys use.
So I think it's kind of cool.
And just to show you
that that all works,
here we have it in Firefox.
This is Dart, compiled
to JavaScript,
using web components deployable
to a production browser today.
This stuff is real
and you can use it.
And then, when you're
finally ready to go,
you have a nice build
directory, which
has just the assets, just
those minified files,
in a very nice directory you can
pick up and put onto the web.
All that concatenation, all
the minification, done for you.
KASPER LUND: Nice and simple.
SETH LADD: Nice and simple.
So, how do you get started?
Well, we relaunched the website,
and we have a really nice code
lab.
It takes under an hour,
walks you through zero to 60.
You get to build a really cool
pirate name badge generator.
A really nice way
to try Dart, built
for if you don't know
anything about Dart.
And I want to leave
you with a reminder
that Dart 1.0 is
for the modern web.
It's a platform
you can use today.
It's easy to get started.
Go to dartlang.org.
We have APIs, code labs,
articles, tutorials.
And everything you saw here,
even the web component stuff,
all compiles to JavaScript.
So you can write
Dart, take advantage
of those great semantics,
language, and tools,
and still deploy
across the modern web.
So I think with that-- I
think we're all ready to go.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.